русич нитки в руку 87 танк його так вже
вся кава автомобіль з США діставав та
морськими шлях кому німецький порту
бремерхафене он і про спочатку для
планового послання і не підрозділі в нато
на кордоні за росію в team в інтернеті
тебе і сталіна було за все меншого
звучанням низько російському розумне кіно
гламурних нові інших сайті спочив і
пасати промо саванний раз гортані вереск
ще сина на позицію москве паном
87 американських танки втілив Ти на
всю інформацію п'ята була десятки сайті
в тріску ширше історії смоли на люблю
америку на люблю над вона любить захід ще
вписаний куща вася
історію з канадського сайту підкупив
агенство ріа новими
основна державна агенція Росії
ви курс the law своєму матеріалі
б наймав один з експертів на шукаю давно
створені ваги противну групи
її робота кулі раю в тому ще позакривати
і сфабриковані але війни і треба ватою
реальний факт їм золото нами буде не
вибори у Франції то не матч і не
викладки для брюсселі дорослим русі
вкладу я всю справа вже й мало людських
ресурсів та чим олігархи
теж я наповнена ще з моєї достатньо
коштувавши рахунок тину про tagged і він і стала
Біляш курним а через вибори у Франції
то ними лагодити його руку all its і будуть
вечеря і простим завданням у темно вище в
євросоюзі з turbo вання ширше ним
фейкових но - витим монолог уточнюючи
канадський прем'єр джастін трюдо виступі
під і лобач і не згорнувся вдома
ріканського каналу fox news
з рисою видали в twitter не правдиві по
видам його ним журналісти назвали жалобу та
стики тільки вам в результаті квебеку
марокканця
мій сон ніж бішма eastern у автора
історії грає на буттєвих струнах тем
день шиття історії траві побоюватися
фейки відсоток таким чином ще за рахунок
і матей ну і складаю проста проти
то раціональний процес
вивішує і гнів образу страх і пачино
та to wear це всьому що пейджем літтям про
тілі маша
прикладом pro 3000 речовини танки в такі
сюжети найкращі частини на інформаційну
винним яку за словами експертів на
заході беляші не може і гну равати їм
лише через вуста не місяці оперативна
група розкрила
2500 а фейкових новим вельми мережа мама
вам і